alors il ya une autre chanson qui
s'appelle côté jardins et côté cour
alors là ça dit il ya toujours le temps
qui courent et moi qui court après vous
oui mais ça a été vrai pendant longtemps
je suis obligé parfois de de me rabattre
sur ma vie passée ça l'est moins
aujourd'hui évidemment vous du court et
plus appris aujourd'hui non non non il
est tranquille sur son lit regarde à
moitié à moitié un infirme enfin bon
non j'exagère
non non c'est plus d'actualité tu finis
maintenant vous avez sorti le fini et
qu'il était donc vous raconter tout ça
mais j'ai ce truc body oui mais on la
connaît par coeur mais absolument très
intéressant
et elle est développée en long et en
large dans les livres de michel les
miennes absolument voilà vous dites que
jacques dutronc vous adresser à la
solitude absolument absolument parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui
pendant des années étaient relativement
absents et même quand il est là il a
quelque chose d'un petit peu de temps
alors je sais que certains font d'un psy
canalise un peu cheap avec ça mais bon
ça y est enfin ça c'est valable quand
même aussi un peu pour un père absent
mari absent
ce que j'ai toujours eu l'espoir de le
voir plus souvent et puis finalement un
jour je n'avais pris votre parti vous
êtes dire oui mais c'est même ne sait
même pas ça quand je dis qu'il m'a
adressées à la solitude c'est c'est que
j'ai été forcé à
assumer assurer une certaine solitude et
que finalement j'ai pris goût et que je
pense que si j'y ai pris goût c'est
parce qu'elle correspondait aussi à ma
nature profonde ce que je ne savais pas
au départ alors pour le menacer vous lui
disiez un jour tout ça me fera ni chaud
ni froid 1 et puis c'est arrivé
non mais c'est pas ça c'est que quand le
quand le temps passe quand on connaît
quelqu'un depuis très très longtemps les
les sentiments évoluent c'est ce que
tout le monde dit c'est la vérité donc
c'est vrai qu'on passe de
de la passion avec tout ce que ça
implique de possessivité de jalousie
d'exclusivisme on passe de ça à une
amitié très particulière très
particulière et finir là tu vois
tu sais quelle chanson qui s'appelle
jardiniers bénévoles ouais vous dites
aimer l'autre c'est laisser vivre oui
mais ça c'est quelque chose que je peux
dire aujourd'hui qu'on pensait déjà
quand j'étais beaucoup plus jeune mais
que je n'aurais pas été capable de faire
parce que quand on est amoureux et qu'on
est jeunes on a envie d'avoir l'autre
pour soi et on fait tout pour l'avoir à
soi et en même temps qu'on fait tout
pour l'avoir à soit on fait exactement
le contraire de ce qu'il faut faire
parce que évidemment ce qu'il faut faire
c'est le laisser le laisser vivre le
laisser libre et
effectivement dans cette chanson je dis
je parle d'envol quoi je parle d'ouvrir
les bras pour que l'autre puis on prenne
son envol et non pas pour l'étouffer un
petit peu plus dans la prison dans
laquelle on aimerait être enfermé avec
lui alors ça n'empêche pas les aventures
il ya une chanson qui s'appelle sur quel
volcan voilà c'est une relation
clandestine
dangereuse cacher oui c'est un peu bon
moi j'ai toujours été fasciné par ça
c'est pas vraiment d'actualité par
rapport à par rapport à moi et à ma vie
j'ai passé un petit peu le cap par
rapport à ces choses là mais j'ai pas
pourquoi ça m'évoque le film parce que
parfois je peux être respect par des
films ça m'évoque le très beau film the
love qui l'important c'est d'aimer
il ya une situation comme ça vous évoque
rien de personnel non non non vous
n'avez jamais eu une aventure comme sa
secrète
non page enfin en tout cas ce que
c'était a tellement vrai
personne ne sait si c'est arrivé c'est
qu'à mon âge encore la mémoire donc si
c'est arrivé j'ai oublié c'est un peu
dommage quand même c'est un peu dommage
couanau bordeaux 12 juillet les choses à
ne pas avoir connu ça je sais pas parce
que je crois que les situations comme ça
c'est beaucoup de souffrance pour tous
beaucoup de soucis beaucoup de soucis
beaucoup de souffrance ccc vous préférez
pas avoir de soucis qu'a voir
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui oui non quand
j'étais plus jeune ça m'est égal je
foncer tête baissée vers le danger
c'est pas toujours été facile avec
dutronc et pourtant vous aviez eu les
plus grandes stars à vos pieds moi je me
trouvais à tomber brian jones mick
jagger
bob dylan c'est vrai quand même
françoise bob dylan c'est vrai mais il
paraît qu est ce qui est vrai
la villa dans 64 genre on dit on est né
en 64 kg s'est passé 2010 mais si je te
dire ce qui s'est passé bob dylan en 64
tombe en arrêt devant une photo de
françoise hardy en couverture de vogue
fait par william klein il en fait
personne ne connaissait bob dylan à
l'époque il venait voir hugues aufray
hugues aufray voulait adapter les
chansons de bob dylan en france donc il
a fait l'autre venait le voir et deux
ans plus tard il revient il est dans sa
loge à l'olympia il refuse de monter sur
scène tant qu'il n'a pas vu françoise
hardy quand même c'est vrai ça ouais
ouais gt gt
je les folles de baume du de bob dylan
j'adorais ses chansons mon rêve c'était
de le voir sur scène il arrive à paris
pour chanter à ce moment là j'étais sur
un tournage
j'ai compris avec yves montand on était
à monaco je suppliais john frankenheimer
de me laisser monter à paris pour le
concert de bob dylan et comme il devait
avoir des penchants un peu sadiques john
frankenheimer il m'a dit le dernier jour
ce moment là veulent m'a dit bon tu peux
aller tu peux aller à paris et puis la
grosse déception parce que bob dylan
n'était pas au meilleur de sa forme
vraiment c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire et il a déçu les attentes du public
car c'était pas ce n'est pas très bon la
manière dont il a chanté dont il a joué
de la guitare et c est donc à l'entracte
il ne revenait pas parce que faisaient
les deux parties est quelqu'un est venu
me demander d'aller dans sa loge parce
que sinon il ne remontait pas sûr voilà
je me souviens absolument pas de ce qui
a pu se passer dans sa loge moi j'étais
terrifiée je vis une espèce de vampires
jaune avec avec des ongles trop la messe
était aux fraises
alors que françois je ne vous raconte
pas c'est qu'ensuite vous allez tous
avec vous ou johnny hallyday hugues
aufray ou georges 5 bob dylan is not
complètement le johnny hallyday zouzou
et gaufres et il vous prend vous dans sa
dans sa suite voyage il me prouve toute
façon je suis trop bien et il vous fait
écouter tu as like a woman i want you ce
sont quand même des grandes chansons oui
vous l'avez vous avez revu après non non
non mais c'est quoi sinon je suis et je
sais j'ai su que récemment quand il
était à paris peut-être pas la dernière
fois mais l'avant dernière fois alors
j'en redemande eux il avait déjà évolué
dans des
schémas maintenant je m'en fous si la
france
enfin bon je sais qu'il a demandé de mes
nouvelles et je préfère qu'il reste avec
le fantasme de la photo de mes 20 ans
plutôt que me voir que voir la ruine que
je suis devenu
chef
de la saisir comme ça arrêtez vous un
bon on passe à la radio
[Musique]
françoise vous pensez à quoi en ce
moment là je pense avoue thierry c'est
quoi vraiment pourquoi vous fait plein
de grimace avec votre bouche là
c'est exactement ça oui j'ai remarqué
qu'il a des dents particulièrement
étincelant non pourquoi ces ou quand
c'est pas des conneries comme ça vous
pensé pour pessah au montage c'est le
moment le plus creux venir dans
l'émission il avait pensé à quoi la met
à vous il ya votre sourire colgate
savent aborder par contre c'est garder
au montage tu ferais quand vous regardez
le matin dans un miroir vous vous dites
quoi
non mais j'ai un miroir vraiment j'ai
déménagé et pas très longtemps et le
miroir on voit rien donc ça va et en
plus comme j'ai pas mes lunettes je vois
encore moins bien les choses donc je ne
me dit rien parce que ça vous voyez
certaine attention non je ne vais pas
vous auriez met à ressembler à quelqu'un
vous étiez petit ressembler à qui quand
j'étais petit mais figurez vous que je
collectionnais des photos d'actrice est
la première actrice que j'ai trouvé
d'une beauté sublime c'était marina
vlady
elle était belle et je crois qu'elle
l'est toujours elle est restée très très
bien à
oui puis à une bardot bien sûr et ma
mère qui m'avait acheté une robe en
vichy rose qui ne m'allait pas du tout
c'est une catastrophe comme je vais
essayer
vous seriez pas être à tout quitter pour
le grand amour
non
non parce que le grand amour est
derrière moi je ne pensais pas qu'on
puisse émettre deux fois dans sa vie à
nager mais plus que deux fois dans ma
vie ça ses premiers indices anna non
mais ça tout le monde le sait même plus
je suis zen jean marie périer
il ya eu un bel acteur anglais
mais ça fait trois questions va faire je
n'ai jamais jamais pas joué ce soir chez
lui les jus de françoise hardy ah ouais
jean marie périer jagan tron est un
acteur anglais qui s'appelait une ride
au moment parce que les qualités mari
voulait pas divorcer et au moment où
françois pas du tout la question c'est
que c'est la question c'était pas ça
pour lui gt gt une aventure quand est-ce
que tu sortais très intéressant pour moi
de porter cette église cet acteur il est
connu et bien non non c'est un acteur
anglais jusqu'en du tsoup cités romeo
nous nous y tenons bon ok c'est au
moment où ils étaient ils étaient ils
étaient vraiment pas mal du tout avec la
laverie c'était l'époque où jean marie
périer était un peu volage un peu un
finder jean marie périer n'a jamais été
volage il l'est devenu quand moi je les
suis alors pourquoi vous êtes allés avec
l'anglais alors
mais parce que parce qu'il était à
tomber alors en vain
et c'est là que dutronc enlevé ses
lunettes qu'il a mis des lentilles et
qu'ils veulent est beau c'est à ce
moment là
non non non mais c'est à dire moi je
suis resté un peu scotché à cet acteur
anglais qui était très embêté que parce
que pour lui c'était pas il avait
n'avait jamais été question d'avoir une
relation suivie avec moi je crois que la
même année d'ailleurs
il a eu dans sa vie moi et brigitte
bardot il a fait plus fort que bob dylan
né
qui n'a eu ni l'une ni l'autre
et donc et qui les voulaient toutes les
deux à temps et donc donc cet acteur
très charmant me voyait de temps en
temps avec avec jacky me disais mais il
est cent fois mieux que moi il est cent
fois mieux que moi c'est avec lui qu'il
faut être il avait raison sa durée quand
même temps mais sa nasse ça a été une
aventure très épisodique ou à très
épisodique mais très agréable
quand avez vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois
quand j'ai
fait ce que je pensais qu'il ya pas
longtemps il ya eu un déluge
terrible et j'en venais de mes courses
avec mon quasi bourré mon panier bourg
etc j'ai glissé sur une feuille retrouvé
les quatre fers en l'air et l'âge est là
ça a été mon entraîneur fit sienne dans
le troisième âge est vraiment génial
[Rires]
vous changeriez quoi en vous si vous
aviez une baguette magique
le cerveau
oui oui je prendrai le cerveau je ne
sais pas moi
détienne emile baulieu tiens que
pourriez-vous dire de plus de négatif
sur vous
je chante comme un pied
c'est vrai et même je chante moins bien
qu'à pied
[Rires]
non je suis d'accord je suis quand même
aussi
alors si votre vie était à refaire
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil je serai je serai moins dociles
moins
et moins moins prévisible un peu plus
insaisissable alcool associations voilà
ça marche tout le temps
il faut nous surprend il faut être
insaisissable faux faux faux
titiller votre instinct mal de conquêtes
mais tu as fait les courses et les noms
je sais pas fait
comment aimeriez vous avez sans m'en
apercevoir
sa suggestion en dormant ah ouais bah
c'est pas moi ma belle mère et moi île
morte dans son sommeil c'est pas drôle
évidemment pour la personne qui se
réveille à côté d'elle mais
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu